[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
la france peut-elle contribuer au réveil
européens dans un 21e siècle chinois
entre 2005 et 2010 9 les investissements
directs chinois sur le sol européen ont
représenté 294 milliards d'euros
comment se positionner face au géant
chinois
dans la perspective de la présidence
française de l'union européenne à
compter du 1er janvier 2022 le sénateur
pascal allizard et la sénatrice gisèle
jourda ont publié un rapport formule en
quatorze propositions pour guider la
politique française et européenne
vis-à-vis de la chine
tout d'abord l'union européenne et la
france gagnerait à renforcer les efforts
entrepris pour obtenir le recensement
des investissements et des prêts chinois
réalisé en europe et actualisée
l'analyse des risques et perspectives
qu'ils présentent
aujourd'hui la pénétration du marché
européen s'appuie sur une extraordinaire
économie de la contrefaçon favorisé par
le développement du commerce
électronique
pour y remédier la défense de la
propriété intellectuelle des brevets des
processus de production et des savoir
faire européen est indispensable
alors que les moyens de soft power
déployés par la chine paraissent
confondre influence et ingérence il est
nécessaire de développer une stratégie
de dissuasion et d'imposer aux médias
diffusant depuis l'étranger les
obligations qui s'imposent aux médias
nationaux
par ailleurs pour réagir à l'avancé
technologique prises par la chine les
rapporteurs appelle à soutenir les
initiatives et financements
communautaires susceptibles de favoriser
l'émergence d'acteurs européens
notamment dans le domaine de la 6 g
sur le plan géopolitique
l'union européenne doit s'affirmer comme
une puissance stratégique stabilisatrice
face à la montée de la rivalité
sino-américaine
pour cela elle doit développer son
régime de sanctions politiques comme
économiques et continuer de mener un
dialogue de haut niveau lucide et
exigeant avec la chine
enfin il est urgent d'améliorer la
relation bilatérale commerciales entre
la chine et l'ue
pour y parvenir le rapport recommande
notamment de mettre en oeuvre un
traitement équitable entre les
entreprises chinoises et européennes et
d'interdire les transferts forcés de
technologie
la france aura un rôle majeur à jouer
dans ces évolutions et il faudra faire
preuve de détermination et d'un certain
courage pour maintenir le cap malgré les
frictions inévitable
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
[Musique]